It's so sad, Hutem. Soon you will reign over all of Upper Egypt.
I know, but the princess I love is far away in Lower Egypt.
You have only to ask her to join you here.
Excellent suggestion. However, our enemies lie in wait. I'll send a secret message. Take care.
Here comes Tutems. He is our very best secret messenger.
Nobody, not even Tutems, will know the contents of your message.
But quietly, nobody must know it.
It takes so long.
It's impossible to read the message.
Alright, now you can go.
Message from Upper Egypt.
Why now?
In a sort!
Oh!
Messenger.
Their message is to move on quickly, of course.
And so, the Greeks.
Right.
Sure.
Thousand years ago, in the Trojan War.
Message to the...
Just do.
Tragic Queen Gladi-
No.
The Trojan War has ended, and we've won.
You to prepare a special dinner, leg of lamb, and to go with the leg of lamb, fresh green beans,
and you're not to forget the wine from Nimaeum.
Get a mess.
And as time went on, we discovered more rapid means of transmitting messages,
Even before Europeans set forth in North America, the first Americans...
Quickly, you have to send a message to Sly Fox.
You will say tonight's meal is running toward the setting sun.
And that he and his hunting braves be ready. Go on.
So right, Sly Fox has the message. He'll be there with his braves to hunt.
We're here, brothers. All of you ready.
He says he would like his buffalo steak with small red apples.
So from century to century, people will try to communicate faster and faster.
A very efficient system was to be invented by a Frenchman, Claude Schaap, in 1793.
Scene will never work.
Now, could you close the door, please, and the windows as well?
Closed up, nothing can get in, nothing at all, right?
But you want everything closed.
Yeah, no, no, no.
Listen to this.
This music come from...
Well, it's on the radio, so...
I'll tell you where it's really coming from.
In fact, it's really coming from an antenna, just like the Eiffel Tower in Paris.
It can even do a bit better.
Close the doors and windows and nothing can come in or go out.
Just look at the rays of the sun.
It's not fair, Maestro.
I mean, sunlight can just pass through the windows.
Oh, yes, well, there are many things around.
Invisible rays, for example, that pass through windows and through walls and all sorts of things.
Oh, invisible rays?
Yes, you and I, we can see only rays of visible light,
but if we were able to see all the others, imagine for a second the confusion.
It would all confuse everybody.
No, no, you can believe me, it's true.
Now, a German, Heinrich Hertz, learned how to transmit waves.
We could create waves, and then transmit them very fast.
Just how fast?
At the speed of light, 300,000 kilometers per second.
Bet we had to learn how to use them.
It's an Italian, Guglielmo Marconi, who was the first to have the idea.
He liked making things, and he was naturally curious.
Even as a child, he did all sorts of experiments.
Father, we'd be furious. You are impo--
I was only trying to find out if I could create a magnetic field.
Am I going to d-- about it, Mom?
together as soon as I've cooked the chicken.
Seppi is so good with his hands.
Yes, but I wish he wouldn't break everything.
I saw him.
Say he's making alcohol, that's all.
That's right.
In the name of the law, you let me come in.
It's an order.
What? The law? But why? What have I done?
The distillation and production of alcohol is not allowed.
Alcohol in my home?
I have to investigate.
Inspection in the name of the law.
It's in there.
My son goes in there to play from time to time.
Oh, he plays?
What exactly are you doing, Guillermo?
It's an experiment, Pop.
The distillation of alcohol is against the law.
It's my son, officer. He's always doing experiments of one sort or another, and he makes mistakes.
Here, you are a prank.
Oh, no, no, no, I insist.
Oh, well, very well, but you are not to do this anymore. And take that still apart.
The exams.
Zoom is useless.
A technical school. Maybe it's just what he needs.
Yes, but I don't see how I can do him any good.
The dynamo produces an electric current, which is transmitted by these wires here.
Bring them close to each other.
In this way, we can transmit messages great distances.
It's the telegraph.
You see, you shouldn't have to use any wires.
A telegraph without wires, you're dreaming, Marconi.
With Branly's device and Popov's antenna,
the higher it is, the farther it will transmit.
Please, do you eat something? I made all your favorites.
Successfully transmitted messages from one end of a room to the other,
and without any wires, do you realize?
Yes, and so?
Well, we ought to be able to use the same technique
and send messages without wires all over the world.
A wireless telegraph you're dreaming, son.
Good boy.
In the attic, I think he's working.
Working? Is that what it is? More likely breaking something.
Last, you'll do us the honor of dining with us?
Oh, good Lord, son. What have you done? You're a mess.
Nothing, Mom. A small accident, that's all.
Mom, I really did it. I want you to be the first to see it.
Go on. Press the small lever. Go on.
Now, as you can see, there are no wires.
Push again.
Oh, yes?
It's just like a telegraph, but there's no wires.
But now, I have to find a way to increase the transmission range.
Then, I will have invented the wireless telegraph, and I'll make you proud.
The hills and the walls block the waves?
Senior Marconi, waves disperse over distance. It's well known.
Do you think you can receive them 20 kilometers away?
Uh, well, the sun's distance is 50 million kilometers.
But yet, we're able to receive its rays. We agree. We feel its heat rays.
That's what we're thinking is we all know nothing is equally power to the sun, and you think you'll do the same?
Well, for the present, we'll be content transmitting to a hill.
There, that one.
My assistant is there waiting.
Nonsense! If you succeed, I will eat my hat!
Be sure that the lady's sending a message and that you could be cheating!
Since you know Morse code, please ask any question you like.
I see.
Ask, how much is two times three?
See, no cheating about it.
Your hat, please?
You said you would eat your hat.
I hope you enjoy it, signori.
But in Italy, nobody was interested in Marconi's work.
In 1896, he went to England.
Cases.
Bombs.
Terrorists.
There's his...
Bombs.
Why no, it's a radio.
Ah, what?
Never heard.
You'll break the...
Mr. Minister, we're going to exchange signals between England and France, a distance of 46 kilometers, and we'll do it with no wires.
Hmm, 30 miles, that's a long way.
You think you can do it?
You will see.
Communication is established.
Good show, Mr. Marconi, your invention interests us.
and to transmit messages over 3,000 kilometers to England.
The antenna has to be long.
Mission in history, Newfoundland to Cornwall.
It's time.
So cold.
Set up a radio station near the North Pole.
We'll transmit all over the world.
Cape Breton.
That's it.
We're here.
Should do it.
Ships.
I'd say they're hundreds of kilometers apart.
The invention of the radio marked the beginning of a new era.
Any information could now be transmitted from one end of the world to the other almost instantaneously.
and for the very first time in history,
ships at sea could communicate with other ships
and with stations on land.
So in 1999,
if the nearest ship was far away,
hundreds of kilometers,
there were tragedies and radio couldn't stop them.
Titanic was able to send out a distress call
and the SOS was heard by several ships
and they rescued survivors.
740 passengers were saved by the radio message,
but it was still only one out of three.
And this dramatic event radioed to the attention of the world
and made Marconi's reputation.
I'll bring you 200,000 pounds sterling for the use of your invention.
The Italian government, 20 million lira.
The Mexican government, 50,000 pesos.
The United States of America, half a million dollars.
Brazil, Poland, Spain, Argentina.
What will I ever do with all of it?
Is it?
There's something important.
Sorry, but there's something I have to see to.
It's possible to transmit pictures, but how?
Marconi was already thinking of television, but it was still too early.
Of course, it was thanks to him that radio spread all over the world.
Played a pot. Search scientists, I believe.
What exactly are we searching for, Bertain?
A small square object with three wires in it, Shockley.
Uh, what is its use?
Well, I don't really know, Bardeen, but I know it'll be obvious.
Found the object.
Wasn't this, but still, this is it.
Now, what will you do with it? Can't be much use.
Watch out, Walter. It's still plugged in.
What I thought, it will intensify electric current.
Like water down a waterfall.
I guess I can't find it.
This it?
Yes, it's small, but it has literally changed our world.
their world this thing has overturned upset revolutionized and turned over our world upside
down and you see what i mean yes it's so small what is it anyway well this my children is a
transistor this is a transistor transistor is this it can amplify the current then detect it
now it can modulate it and do anything you like with it tv sets computers washing machines airplanes
satellites you name it it's with this we communicate we travel we have a look at
events all over the world we call that progress